what's going on guys you might be asking
why the suit well I got to be in court
in a couple hours but it's also time for
the screen the awards show that you know
and love also the only award show that
has a host thank god I deleted all of my
old tweets let's begin shall we
starting off it's the it's all downhill
from here award signaling the point in
the year after which everything was
garbage and the winner is January 12th
Paddington - that's right after that
brief moment of joy 2018 was pretty much
all downhill from there
so just drown myself in a jar of
marmalade up next it's the British
whimsy award this is the award for the
2018 film that delivered the most
British whimsy the nominees are
Paddington - Mary Poppins returns the
favorite Christopher Robin and the
winner is Black Mirror Bandersnatch
Congrats on your screaming after all
what's more whimsical than a
choose-your-own-adventure now if you
want to move onto the next screen II
click to the left if you want to search
for the treasure of pirate Cove click to
the right if you clicked either of those
choices
you probably pause the video welcome
back our next screen E is the JK trollin
award
it's the award we give out every year to
the Harry Potter scribe JK Rowling for
the weird choices she makes that pretty
much troll her loyal fan base and the
winner is wizards pooping on the floor
JK worked some real magic this year but
the tweet that wins the house Cup was
Pottermore making it cannon that Wizards
you suggest their robes X belly anus
open a new tab in your incognito browser
because it's the mainstream movie that
sounds like a porno O'War
the nominees are the Nutcracker in the
four realms truth or dare
Juliet naked the rider first man the Meg
to all the boys I've loved before the
knight comes for us thoroughbreds early
man and the winner is the mule there's
no clear winner this year but the mule
could definitely be a very specific kind
of porno made for a very specific group
of folks no judgement here okay a little
bit judgment like if you're into mule
stuff what it like what exactly is mule
stuff tell us in the comments below
what's mule stuff and now the best movie
with my name as the title and the winner
is how hey that's my name hey everybody
are you ready for the best movie where
the words Solo in the title Award winner
is free solo
sorry solo a Star Wars story any other
year you would have had a locked up
actually not a guarantee if they ever
reboot Mario Van Peebles solo you're in
trouble
hmm it's time for the Leo DiCaprio give
me that Oscar Award for the actor making
the most blatant play for Oscar gold and
the screen he goes to Steve Carell who
did a drug addiction drama beautiful boy
a pic welcome to Marwin and a real-life
political satire vise to get that Oscar
sorry Steve looks like you're gonna have
to eat a bison heart put on an unhealthy
amount of weight and do a churchill
accent to breakthrough next year this
one a true fan favorite the Tom Hardy
greatest achievement in covering your
face award previous winners include Tom
Hardy in Dark Knight Rises mr. Tom Hardy
and Mad Max fury road Tom Hardy in
Dunkirk and the winner is Tom Hardy in
venom yes Tom Hardy you've kept the
streak alive
keep it up Tom here's hoping your
upcoming Al Capone movie features a
scene where Al puts on a mask and goes
to a Halloween party or something I got
a good feeling about this next award
though folks it's the best sci-fi movie
about
man enhanced by a symbiotic intelligence
that turns him into a killing machine
award and the winner is upgrade Wow
shocker venom you're super fun but uh
honestly everyone should see upgrade
it's like venom but without the goo mmm
we've got a very competitive race and
this year's achievement and brutally
murdering a room full of people award
it's a tight race the nominees the
butcher scene and the night comes for us
the apartment seen in the night comes
for us and the car scene in the night
comes for us the winner the club scene
in the night comes for us I've never
seen a bottle put into a man's mouth
quite that horrific aliy time now for
the do you ever sleep award this one
goes to Tiffany Haddish she was in two
music videos for movies and a TV series
in 2018 Plus announcing the Oscar
nominations hosting an mtv movie and TV
awards doing drunk history becoming the
face of Groupon and launching her own
brand of seasoning salt hey Dwayne the
rock Johnson while you're sleeping for
13 minutes uh Tiffany Haddish ate your
lunch and finished it off with some
brand name seasoning salt with her name
on it and now the craziest social media
feud award the nominees are Sacha Baron
Cohen vs. Roy Moore Katt Williams and
Tiffany Haddish Whoopi Goldberg vs.
Roseanne Barr the winner
Lady Gaga fans vs. venom fans a star is
born and venom opened same weekend and
the little monsters did everything they
could to try and tank Venom's opening
two films poised on the edge of glory
one about paparazzi dreams the other
about bad romance
despite gaga fandoms best attempts venom
maintained its poker face and just
danced its way to massive international
box office success and I think I deserve
some applause for the number of Gaga
puns in this bit this one is a very
controversial award or maybe it's not
it's the can we throw it into the Sun
award
it's the award for the creepy
most off-putting thing in entertainment
in 2018 the nominees for things that we
want to throw into the Sun our Star Wars
fans chasing Star Wars stars off social
media bringing racist Hulk Hogan back to
host a WWE event in Saudi Arabia Logan
Paul just in general the Byrd Box
challenge hurting toddlers the winner
Kevin Spacey's creepy as hell response
to sexual assault allegations in
character as Frank Underwood
hey NASA who throw Kevin Spacey into the
Sun this one is the Mandy Award for
achievements in cocaine-fueled chainsaw
fighting the nominees the cocaine-fueled
chainsaw fight and Mandy and the winner
oh what an upset it's the cocaine-fueled
chainsaw swinging else in Christmas
Chronicles Wow sorry Mandy the moral
here you should see Mandy and Christmas
Chronicles in a double feature and let
the kids watch whoa time out it's time
for the classic characters most in need
of a timeout award the nominees Robin
Hood older versions of classic
characters that are now middle-aged and
sad Mowgli and the winner Sherlock
Holmes to Sherlock movies this year the
Sherlock Assange was over in 2010 move
on this next one oh it's a biggie the
least necessary post : subtitle in a
movie title award the nominees are solo
: a Star Wars story Sicario : day of the
Soldado mowgli : legend of the jungle
and the winner the girl in the spider's
web : a new Dragon Tattoo story
hey girl in the spider's web it's a new
story we sumed that oh this one's
exciting it's the breakthrough performer
of the Year award the nominees are the
girls of blockers Halloweens and he met
a check latisha writes shorey from black
panther the screen e goes to
the chicken that knows math from the
ballot of Buster Scruggs look all the
actors that we mentioned were incredible
they're gonna have long massive careers
but that chickens on borrowed time I'm
gonna eat that math chicken
move over youngsters it's time for the
angry grizzled old man award the
nominees are Bruce Willis in death wish
Denzel Washington and equalizer - Liam
Neeson in the Commuter Michael Myers in
Halloween Josh Brolin a Deadpool - Clint
Eastwood in the mule and the screen he
goes to epidemis enters infinity war
Congrats ebony ma we will all stay off
your lawn it's time for the crazy rich
Asian Award for the craziest rich Asian
the nominees are Michelle Yeoh crazy
rich Asians Constance Wu crazy rich
Asians
aquafina for crazy rich Asians and the
winner is BD Wong for Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom now BD Wong was not in
crazy rich Asians but he literally in
these movies is a crazy rich asian I
gotta assume lead geneticist at Jurassic
Park or Jurassic world is gonna make you
pretty rich he's crazy because he keeps
making these murder dinosaurs that just
keep ruining stuff all his plans go
horribly awry yet he keeps doing it
Congrats BD Wong got stopped screening
this next one is a very prestigious
award this is the most prestigious
prestige television show award the
nominees are
Patrick Melrose escape at Dannemora
sharp objects homecoming
the screen he goes to reruns of the
office cuz I am watching those other
shows but reruns of the office are
always gonna be good sometimes I don't
understand those Christy just shows
folks that was our last award but we are
not done yet let's take a moment and
honor the things we said goodbye to in
[Music]
your movie sucks so bad
you sound real bad
don't screwed
[Music]
it's your fault
we all
your movie sucks so bad
[Music]
you sound real bad
don't squirt
[Music]
it's your phone
we all want
[Music]
hope you guys had fun I did did we miss
anything from last year you have an idea
for a new screen II award did you hate
one of the awards that we did this year
just tell us in the comments below we'll
see you a year from now for the next
installment of the screen ease bye bye